[Music]  the party is here  jasmine or friends definitely had a lot  to drink  but it's nice to know jasmine wants to  be a part of her celebration  even though it's at the end of the night  did you have a good time yes i got wild  but she's their fault  me surprise  wait what did you say  no no no  all right  what the hell who is this guy  for for bad girl  what is this [ __ ]  normal  only down  i can't remember that oh my gosh  [Music]  my friends brought this stupid i didn't  know was in shock you know no problem  normal  are you mad at me  you know  i mean i don't like it  [Music]  [Music]  jasmine should have never had a stripper  at this party to begin with  but you know why why are her friends  showing me a video of jasmine with a  stripper what's the point of that  [Music]  and jasmine's laughing along with her  friends  you know why is she laughing with them  it's like she doesn't even care how i  feel or  or anything  [Music]  you